when I went to your website for is it
red real video production yeah you have
in the bio there which is great it was
founded around 2009 and you say
something out of it was born out of the
recession because if you can't get a job
out of college you might as well do
exactly what you want to do yeah even
though we're supposedly in a robust
recovery I know a lot of people are
still feeling the effects of the
recession can you talk about creating
your own job essentially yeah well I
yeah I graduated in 2008 and didn't
really I went to business school because
I was filming since I was a kid bought
my first camera and I was 13 but I don't
think it ever really occurred to me that
filmmaking could be a possibility it was
just way too cool for me he like didn't
even it didn't even occur to me that
that was ever going to happen that
didn't even cross my mind so yeah I ran
away from home when I was about 16 and
so there was kind of a pull yourself up
by your bootstraps kind of big
recognition of oh I need to have
stability in my life so when I did go to
college it was for business and focused
on that but went to a liberal arts
school called Fort Lewis College in
Durango Colorado and had amazing
professors that really let me do
whatever I wanted with projects and turn
in videos and it was a great atmosphere
to be in to learn about who I was and
what I wanted to be and after graduating
from there there was just you know not a
lot of jobs it was the the peak of
everyone getting fired from places and
so I decided I would do video production
and that started with you know wedding
videos or tutorials for was really
connected with the outdoor industry at
that time so Osprey backpacks and things
like that where they need to do four by
three videos on deep V DV tapes and the
YouTube had barely even started so
was just a different time period and
slowly slowly gained confidence enough
to make my first film and it just kind
of took off from there I think you had
made some short films about aspiring
people in the sort of environmental
space yeah I had made a film before that
called 23 feet that was about people
living simply to do what they loved in
the outdoors and took that on a kind of
unorthodox tour where the film was
called 23 feet because I was the size of
my Airstream and I created a screen that
came down from the Airstream and had an
outdoor city theater tour where in 30
different places around the West showed
the film and they out and outside it was
places like you know Tuolumne meadows
that said yosemite to like 30 climbers
to a blocked off street in Portland
Oregon with 300 people so it was an
amazing very unique distribution
strategy but I just had no idea about
film festivals or anything like that but
what I did find was people would come up
to me after the screenings or write me
letters later about how they had decided
to you know quit their day jobs and you
know empty their Rentals out and move
into a van and decided to just like you
know live the life that they've always
wanted to live and it was really jolting
to get these letters from people who had
decided to change their life after
seeing a film I had made and really
spoke to how powerful films get me so
after that I'd made move shake which was
a series about people who are dedicating
their lives to their passions of
environmental and social justice and
that was a big learning experience but
made several short films and a it was
what led me to making my first feature
in Afghanistan called frame by frame
that was about Afghan photojournalists
and so it's always like getting away
from the outdoor industry and more into
topics that I was interested in around
storytelling do you think if it hadn't
been during the time of the recession
that you would have been less apt to try
that just because you saw so many things
were falling apart that we didn't think
we're gonna fall apart yeah I think it's
probably not good to say but I might be
the only person who's thankful for the
recession because it was I think I could
have very easily just gotten a marketing
job somewhere if it would have been a
different time but it really forced me
to think okay I could do a job I really
don't want to do and make okay money or
I could do exactly what I want to do and
push myself and that was a scary scary
risk and leap to take but really glad it
turned out that way obviously how
committed do you have to be to want to
turn your life over to a story how
committed do I have to be to turn my
life over to a story I mean I definitely
with frame-by-frame and on her shoulders
my two features completely gave
everything that I had almost disappeared
in a way to make these films so I think
that's what I've done I don't
necessarily think it's healthy or
sustainable or but in a lot of ways I
don't know how else to make films I yeah
that might be a personality thing but I
think in order to really tell a true
story you have to kind of give yourself
over to it and be that passion dedicated
and no one's gonna be it's such it's so
much work and it takes so long and it is
so hard that and no one's really gonna
give as much of this it was about
it as you are so you kind of just have
to give your entire self to it
especially because I'm a shooter
director editor that does a lot of
producing work too it's um
yeah it takes it takes every bone in my
body yeah what advice would you have for
another documentary filmmaker who knows
that about themselves as well like Oh
okay I have to really be passionate
about something and I can't do a certain
job and sit there forty hours a week and
I know I want to do this but I also know
how emotionally tough this is going to
be not just for me but for my quote
unquote subject I think it's important
to know going into especially feature
film that giving yourself over to it and
the emotional strain and stress is going
to be a part of it and that that's
normal I think a big part of my first
feature it was just like being hard on
myself for being hard on myself and or
just stick you know not being able to
handle the emotional strain and thinking
that it was abnormal but most people go
through that scary time of like is this
the right way to tell this story am i
doing it justice am i doing the right
thing this is really hard I have no idea
what I'm doing are we gonna get the
money all the scary things that happened
feeling really stressed out about that
and are not stressed but you know very
uncertain uncertainty is normal writ
like the feeling of risk it feels normal
and you can get used to that part but I
don't think it ever becomes easier but
at least you could be nicer to yourself
in the process
so frame by frame was was difficult
you're saying but I think I heard you
say that on her shoulders was definitely
the toughest that you've taken on in
terms of making a film yeah I think well
I mean topic wise and it was very a very
fast
production but definitely handling the
subject matter was very intense but with
both with both films it was yea
incredibly a huge journey to get from
start to finish so and each one very
unique and very different so but yeah it
was definitely the hardest on her
shoulders was definitely the hardest
thing I've ever done in my life that's
for sure how did you first hear of Nadia
I remember seeing Nadia's speech in
December of 26 our December of 2015 at
the UN Security Council and I think it
was either
video on Facebook or something like that
that they had chaired the speech and I
remember taking notice of that and and
and also paying attention to the
genocide that started in August of 2014
but it wasn't until July of 2016 that
riot the production company reached out
for me to make a short film about Nadia
and wanted me to make that and so I met
her two weeks later and after meeting
her it was very obvious that it should
be a feature film to not only do justice
to her story but we were the only ones
with the access that we had and so it
felt like a huge responsibility to do
justice to it and bring nuance to the
issue and to her story so Hayley Pappas
who's your producer she's the one that
introduced you to Nadia in terms of
making this short riot gotten access to
Nadia and their team through Elizabeth
Shaffer brown who was working with Nadia
and still works with Nadia
they approached riot and suggested some
sort of collaboration and that's when my
the producer of the film
Hayley Pappas reached out to me and so
initially it was a short film at what
point did you say oh no this has to be a
feature I think about a week into
filming with Nadia I realized that that
couldn't be a short definitely wanted it
to be a feature and that was a scary
thing to propose the production company
they definitely were not interested and
didn't want to make a feature and so for
the post production I was making it in
secret but as soon as they saw the first
the first rough-cut and I spoke to them
about the importance of it especially to
the one of our executive producers Ben
moszer had a conversation with him about
why it needed to be a feature and showed
him the rough
cut and then they finally got him bored
but there was a scary space of time for
her I had no idea what was gonna happen
but then after it was decided that it
would be a feature they came on board
with all the financing and everything
thankfully were able to do so so the
film is is so much a woman's story of
you know sort of like this reluctant
celebrity in some ways and very
necessary for her to tell this story but
it's also an interesting look at our
media and you see the the questions that
are asked over and over again to Nadia
and they're very painful some are
necessary and some it seems like maybe
they're pushing the envelope a little
too much or going too far with it
especially the sensitive nature of
everything what were some of the
questions that you had to ask
Nadia before you began the movie had you
know did she really want to go through
with this how was this to have you
essentially as part of her life for this
period of time yeah I I went into making
the film very aware and very cautious
about how I gained access as a
storyteller into this film because you
know I needed to be very cognizant of
the fact that the access I was gaining
with Nadia was because she felt that she
needed to make the film it was just yet
another thing where it was like yes
anything to get the word out if you feel
like a documentary will help sure and so
that's a very strange space to be in as
far as the documentary filmmaker with
access and really made me question you
know everything that we were doing and I
was very conscious of it not only at the
beginning of it throughout filmmaking of
how that influenced the story but in
general that conversation was very quick
and she was like yeah sure let's let's
do it so but I think after seeing
interviews that Nadia had done and the
questions that were being asked I had no
idea going in what kind of impact this
telling her story over and over again
would have on her
and seeing that you know through a long
lens watching her and listening to her
it took a piece of her every single time
and it was very soon into the film that
I really wanted to focus on not only
what I was seeing but at what I was
grappling with as far as a storyteller
and our sense of responsibility to the
stories that were telling especially
such traumatic stories I thought what
was really telling too was the other
people's reaction to the camera and and
one scene in particular that really
stuck out was I don't know if she was in
the US or Canada she was going down an
escalator and these girls were coming up
and they wanted to be in the shot and
they thought you know but but the thing
is it's an interesting look at how we're
in this new landscape where people want
this sort of attention but they probably
had no idea why she was being filmed and
the reasons around it so I just thought
that was such an interesting contrast of
showing just the reaction to everybody
who's being interviewed but the subject
matter and the reason for it
are things that most people wouldn't
survive even retelling twice so I just
thought that was very interesting look
at where we are right now with media and
you know people wanting to get their
channel out or their Instagram account
mmm yeah yeah I think Nadia saw those
women on the escalator and thought it
was endearing and I think I wanted to
show you know a big part of showing her
and seems like getting her hair done or
the shopping it's like pulling us out
and making us conscious that you know
this is at the end of the day a 23 year
old woman that is just a young woman who
likes makeup and doing her hair and
clothes just like the rest of us yeah
and just wanted people to get a sense of
her personality through those images
yeah is the film you set out to make the
film that eventually was made is the
film I set out to make the one I
eventually made I didn't set out to make
a film
of course ice to make a film but I
didn't have any preconceived notions of
what this film was going to be and that
is a part of my directing process
because I don't of course I did a lot of
research on musi DS and about nadia but
I don't want to define what the story is
before I'm actually with the people and
so the film is created through the
experiences I'm having with everyone and
what I'm seeing what I'm witnessing the
questions I'm asking the answers I'm
hearing that's what shapes the the story
way more than the research that I did
before the film you have a quote that I
think you you quoted on the late artist
George O'Keeffe and it's a great quote
it says I have already settled it for
myself so flattery and criticism go down
the same drain and I'm quite free that
sounds wonderful and we're in a new age
where we can all have these opinions and
put them out there whether they're
harmful or not where did you and how did
you get to that point where you're free
from you know that you always hear well
if you believe the good then you have to
believe the bad kind of thing question
is interesting yeah I guess you might
have seen that unlike my facebook
there's no um I think it was I was like
women in film it was a QA or something
oh it was a written QA okay sorry
yeah I really loved that George O'Keeffe
quote I mean she's definitely a source
of huge inspiration for me and really
look after her work in a lot of ways I
think that kind of I think especially as
women we're just so pressured to be
certain things or not allowed to be
other things that men can be a full
range of especially as artists that it's
not until you're in the distribution
process of going to festivals and doing
press site I even really realize that I
am a director because I'm a shooter
editor and I'm just making my film and
I'm
doing this thing and it's really
actually not even until I come out that
people are like Oh female director
Alexandria Vaughn back and I'm just like
oh yeah I guess I am a female and I
guess I am a director and you know
there's kind of these things that and
and you know I think boxes that you're
put in and all this stuff and it can be
kind of damaging to your process of the
actual making of films so for me I don't
read the reviews I try and stay away
from yeah being put in these boxes it's
incredibly difficult but it's important
for me to just kind of put my head down
and do the work rather than do the work
defined by other people or what I
shouldn't be doing or what they think
I'm doing or what they think I'm doing
wrong or right I just want to do I want
to have responsibilities to my subjects
and do justice to their stories and do
that in a way that I feel is true to
myself we had a few questions come in
from our YouTube viewers and this one is
from ms green and she writes how has
what you've seen over time changed your
view of life and does it ever show up in
your filming or do you edit it out oh I
think the films I'm making are
definitely starting from my experience
and a lot of them have to do with how
I'm questioning how we're operating in
this human experience at all
so with frame by frame I there was just
so many questions I was having as a
storyteller about our perception and
where that comes from and one of the
make a film about Afghan photographers
to talk about perception of a place that
is so often this unknown known in a lot
of ways and with on her shoulders I was
really interested and I mean this is
kind of feeding off of that in a way
where it was continuing telling a story
about storytelling and the repetition
and the packaging of stories of trauma
and how we're receiving that
as an audience and our own relationship
with apathy and empathy through these
stories and so I don't think I would
ever make a film where I already had the
answer
I already feel very strongly about
things like cigarettes or single-use
plastic and I don't think I would ever
make a film about it because I already
know how I feel about it
I think all of these films are questions
that I'm also asking myself and I think
that's maybe where the energy comes from
and and relates to an audience asking
themselves questions too um I think
that's where it all comes from is my own
questioning of life and how I'm
experiencing the world yeah where does
your love for storytelling come from I
mean you had gone you said to study
marketing for and I can see why and it
sounds like you took your love of the
environment and or different things and
wanted to add that to your marketing
plan or whatever but where does your
love for storytelling and film come from
I definitely have loved making videos
since I was a kid I I don't know it's a
hard question to ask where does my love
for storytelling come from because I'm
having a such a complicated relationship
with storytelling even now after making
on her shoulders and really questioning
where we're coming from the storytellers
and our responsibility to our subjects
and who's telling what story and and and
why we're telling it and all sorts of
different things so it's an interesting
space to be and now I know that I don't
want to stop this work and then we'll
continue to make documentaries and
probably die with a camera in my hands
but I don't even know where that comes
from I think I have no idea I think I
feel like each film I make though is
kind of a exploration of things that I'm
questioning about life it's a process of
pulling things out of myself and
answering hard questions so it's a it's
I just love the process
of it I love all of that and of course
it takes me to and just introduces me to
people that I would never have met and I
mean it's such an honor to have met
Nadia even though I wish of course that
I would never have met Nadia I wish none
of this would have ever happened and she
was just still you know an unknown
person in a village in Sinjar but I am
so so thankful that I got to meet these
people and be exposed to their patience
and grace and empathy so I can see the
world in a different way it's um quite a
gift and hopefully that's translated to
the audience to the intimacy with your
shots of Nadia I was wondering if you
could talk about why you chose the the
beautiful black background and as sort
of this confessional style yeah it was
important for me with without her
shoulders with the storytelling -
especially the cinematography to have a
sense of intimacy so much of the things
that people have seen from Nadia of
course are coming for more of a
journalism background so and people are
interviewing her you know two-thirds of
the frame and I just wanted to disrupt
the way that we're used to hearing from
her let alone the way we're used to
hearing from survivors or you Z's or
just survivors in general I wanted
people to feel close to her so a lot of
the shots are close-up shots on a long
lens to give that feeling of almost
sitting next to her as people are
communicating with her talking with her
that you're sitting beside Nadia she's
going through this thing because a big
part of the film is I think people think
going in the film will be about Nadia
but in reality it's a filmer us in our
how we understand storytelling and
apathy and empathy and in that same vein
wanted to do something different in the
interview where she wasn't going to be
2/3 of the frame
looking off screen I wondered everything
does this appear and you were just
looking at her and she was looking you
in the eyes while she was talking about
this stuff
I also avoided any questions about her
actual captivity or escape because I
think the film is trying to make you
question why you need to even know those
details in the first place and I also
put a huge emphasis on making sure that
those were longer cuts and uncut
interviews sections which is was a hard
thing to figure out but finally got that
placed well because I wanted you to be
with her as she you know maybe went in
another direction in the middle of her
sentence or or decided to talk about
something else or hesitated before
saying something and that took a lot of
work in the translations to try and make
that as nuanced as possible because how
we had heard from her in the past of
course was either live translations at
the UN or someone sitting next to we're
translating her this was the first time
that I felt like people could really if
you are not speaking heard one dialect
of Kurdish and c'mon G that you can
really really hear from her what she's
saying and trying to express which was
very important to me in telling this
story
what's one question you wish the
journalist had asked her well I think
Donnie explains that in the film she
definitely wants people to focus more on
the issue rather than the sensationalism
of the story of her personal story I
think she she's very smart she
understands why it's important to for
people to know just how horrible Isis
has been but it is disappointing when it
doesn't eventually lead to these more
powerful questions of what can be done
what's next and what's the current state
of other girls besides Nadia so but she
expresses that very beautifully in the
film for those of you who enjoy this
content and live in Los Angeles we
invite you to experience film courage
live we have two upcoming events this
Tuesday October 16th we
have a filmmaking panel with filmmakers
Christopher Rea Andrew P Jones Royce
Gorsuch Orson Ovitz and Brian Aven and
Bradley and on Tuesday October 23rd we
have a one-night-only class with Pamela
J Smith entitled mythic challenges
creates stories that change the world we
are excited to host both events we have
links in the description below if you
would like to attend